die 7 vs white Staffel 2 Produktion war
mit großen filmerischen und
organisatorischen Aufwand verbunden für
einen Teil des Teams fingen die wirklich
zermürbende Arbeit allerdings erst nach
Rückreise in Deutschland wieder an wie
das Team mit wenigen Leuten die
16-teilige Serie in kürzester Zeit
aufbaut designt animiert und schneidet
erfahrt ihr in dieser Folge vom
Geheimnis wenn ihr auch in Zukunft nicht
verpassen wollt was hinter den Kulissen
von 7s world Staffel 2 passiert und ihr
uns unterstützen möchtet dann abonniert
diesen Kanal
die heutige Folge wird euch präsentiert
von Coro bei denen ihr 5% aufs gesamte
Sortiment mit dem Code Dave sparen
können sonst nix wie diesen Reis
Krispies über Cookies bisschen zu
allerlei Schokolade gibt es ihr wisst es
schon so ziemlich alles was ihr am
Snacks für den perfekten 7 vs wild am
braucht außerdem gibt es eine Menge
superfoods die euch dabei helfen euch
gesünder zu ernähren und das beste Choro
setzt auf Fähre und nachhaltige
Produktion die großen Verpackungsgrößen
bei Chore machen es möglich euch zum
einen besseren Preise anbieten zu können
und zum anderen auf unnötigen
Verpackungsmittel zu verzichten klickt
jetzt auf den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung bestätigt eure Snacks
und spart dauerhaft mit dem Code Dave 5%
auf gesamte Sortiment ich bedanke mich
vielmals bei Coco und euch viel Spaß mit
dem Video
einmal mein Name ist Patch ich bin der
Director photography kurz DOP von Simon
vs wild meine Aufgabe besteht im
Endeffekt darin dass die ganzen tollen
Sachen die sich Max und Johannes so
ausdenken auch aufgezeichnet wird und
dann für euch sichtbar gemacht wird für
die Kameraarbeit haben wir uns ein
langjährigen Freund gesucht und zwar Pad
mit Peter haben wir schon mehrere Jahre
zusammengearbeitet wir wissen er macht
gute Arbeit ist einfach ein krasser
drogenpilot auch ähm was sehr sehr
wichtig ist hier für die ganzen
Überleitung innerhalb der Serie da
wussten wir die Kamera arbeitet ist in
guten Händen deswegen war das eigentlich
no brainer für uns dass wir den da an
Bord haben wollen was dieses Projekt ja
so besonders und einzigartig macht ist
das eigentlich der Großteil des Content
von den Teilnehmern selber gefilmt wird
sie sind da unter Umständen sieben Tage
draußen wir haben keine Kontrolle
darüber was sie da aufzeichnen hinterher
können wir einfach nur gucken ah okay
hat geklappt oder hat auch nicht
geklappt ja der Akku Wechsel
funktioniert hat und das ist natürlich
schon da ist man vielleicht so ein
bisschen nervös wir wissen einfach nicht
genau was passiert jetzt noch was machen
die gerade aber das macht eben dann
nachher auch den Charme dieses Projekts
aus und wir haben ja vorher vieles
gemacht wir haben vorbereitet wir haben
versucht den die Kameratechnik genau
außen zu erklären fritz war da auch mit
dabei so als ich sag mal Musterschüler
ja der kann das dann in anderen
Teilnehmern auch noch mal ein bisschen
nahe bringen so auch vom letzten Jahr so
macht er das so macht ihr das so ne du
siehst hier läuft die Zeit Wiese normal
laufende 23 Sekunden hier rein guckt
siehst du auch fünf sechs das werde ich
immer super einschalten
damit die Teilnehmer aber auch 7 Tage
lang die Erlebnisse filmen können
befinden sich im Kamera Kit neben
Kleinigkeiten wie Kabel oder Hüllen zwei
GoPro 4 GoPro Akkus zwei powerbanks und
14 SD-Karten in der Theorie können die
Teilnehmer mit diesem Equipment 28
Stunden hochgerechnet auf 7 Teilnehmer
und potentielle 7 Tage ergeben sich also
bis zu 196 Stunden Roma Material wir
haben auch extra zwei GoPro dabei
einfach dann können die auch noch ein
bisschen das Bild einfach variieren kann
man eine total aufstellen können die
andere Kamera in in die Hand nehmen
selbst wenn du eine Kamera verlierst
hast du immer noch eine Kamera die alles
aufzeichnet ja und am Ende des Tages
letztes Jahr ist ja auch super
funktioniert das Risiko das hier
wirklich irgendwas passiert und footage
komplett weg ist haben wir eigentlich
schon sehr minimiert ja die erste
Staffel letztes Jahr die war ja so ein
bisschen als Versuch gedacht
dementsprechend war die Kameratechnik
auch noch ein bisschen einfacher was
dieses Jahr dementsprechend aber dazu
gekommen ist weil es eben größer
geworden ist dass wir gesagt haben alle
Aufnahmen die abseits eben von diesem
bloggingstil der Teilnehmer gemacht
werden dass wir da noch mal sagen okay
wir besorgen dann neue gute Drohnen wir
haben z.B auch ein Gimbal damit was
Helikopter sehr gut filmen können wir
haben drei neue Kameras gekauft Sony a7s
ja bei so einer Produktion die eben so
spontan und auch mal mit dem engen
Zeitplan stattfinden muss lohnt es sich
hier am Set nicht auf die größten Kino
Kameras oder so zu setzen sondern unser
Wert ist eben eher das ist ganze
portable bleibt schnell aufgebaut ist
auch gut zu tragen ist aber dann
trotzdem eben den höchsten Standard
eigentlich bietet ja die Sony a7s die
filmt in 4K bis zu 120p das heißt wir
können das super slomos draus machen
dann wiegt diese Kamera aber eben nur
zwei Kilo zusammen mit dem Objektiv und
das war uns eben einfach wichtig dass
wir da nicht das schwere equipment was
andere Produktion vielleicht verwenden
würden sondern eher ein Level drunter
aber macht halt keine Einbußen in der
Qualität dementsprechend ja also max und
Johannes haben sich ja wirklich sehr
krasse Sachen überlegt da kommt man auch
gerne mal an seine Grenze und dann
Herausforderung wie z.B fällt mir das
allererstes ein der das Opening also
quasi der drop of weil eben wenn bei den
Helikoptern die Türen abgebaut ich habe
mich da reingesetzt mit dem Gimbal und
habe versucht dementsprechend mit zwei
Füßen auf den Kuchen des Helikopters mit
offenen Türen und 300 km/h Wind im
Gesicht diese Aufnahmen zu machen so
Gimbal macht ihr sehr stabile Aufnahmen
aber wenn er 300 km/h Wind auf so Gimbal
prallt dann gibt er auch hin und wieder
mal auf hatte zwischendurch hat er sich
komplett eingedreht da muss ich in die
gucken dass das wieder funktioniert aber
am Ende des Tages hat auch das wirklich
gut funktioniert und ich glaube da haben
wir einfach die richtigen technischen
Mittel gewählt und das dann auch aufzu
speichern ja wie ich schon erwähnt habe
wollten wir in diesem Jahr der die
Qualität noch mal ein bisschen höher
machen und auch noch mal einen
draufsetzen was so Bildgestaltung angeht
gleichzeitig wollten wir aber natürlich
den Stil des ganzen Projekts nicht
verändern ihr erinnert euch vielleicht
letztes Jahr gab es ja in der Serie
diese diese
vorstellungs-shots der Teilnehmer in
Slomo was wir im Hintergrund geregnet
hat die haben vielleicht ein Move
gemacht das wollten wir dieses Jahr
jetzt nicht komplett verändern aber eben
noch ein draufsetzen somit haben wir uns
eben bewegt sich über Shots überlegt wo
wir mit dem Gimbal erst von unten
hochkommen die Teilnehmer so eine Art
Hero Pose einnehmen können noch mal so
irgendwie sich selber in ihre Identität
definieren können den Sascha z.B hatte
einen Stock abgebissen und sich das
hinterher an die Kehle gehalten solche
Geschichten einfach um dann noch ein
bisschen einen drauf zu setzen aber eben
nicht in den Stil vom letzten Jahr nicht
komplett zu verändern sondern eben in
diese in dieser Optik quasi zu bleiben
also das absolutes Highlight was wir
hier erlebt haben fällt mir sofort ein
damit die drohnenaufnahmen gemacht mit
dem Boot Rico und ich waren zusammen im
Boot und wir mussten die letzten
Aufnahmen machen von den eigenen Spots
und dann neben uns sind einfach kleine
Buckelwale aufgetaucht
und der Witz war am Anfang habe ich
gedacht ist ein kleine Buckelwale bis
dann hinterher dass das Muttertier von
den von dem kleinen hoch gekommen ist
hinterher 5 Buckelwale auf einmal ich
habe sofort die Drohne gestartet und
habe versucht den dementsprechend
hinterher zu fliegen und habe es einfach
geschafft ein 10-minütigen shot am Stück
aufzunehmen wo die ganze Zeit diese
Buckelwale drauf sind wo der kleine
immer wieder aus dem Wasser springt am
Anfang dann kommt das Mutter Theo hoch
die beiden tanzen da zusammen so im
Wasser ich habe schon gedacht besser
geht's eigentlich nicht und dann kam
auch noch größere wahrscheinlich
männliche Tiere ich habe ja auch keine
Ahnung von seinem Mann größere Tiere
noch dazu und sind dann alle zusammen im
Wasser geschwommen und das war so einer
generell in meiner Karriere einer der
geilsten Shots diese über überhaupt
gemacht habe hinterher auf 50%
Geschwindigkeit runter ist der shot 20
Minuten lang ich überlege die ganze Zeit
schon ob ich da irgendwie so ein
entspannungsclip dementsprechend draus
mache es einfach ist atemberaubend schön
insgesamt eine Geisteskranke Produktion
ist riesig verloren ich bin mega mega
stolz auf das ganze Team bin sehr sehr
dankbar dass wir alle dabei hatten war
eine mega geile Erfahrung und wir sind
super froh dass alle Teilnehmer
ungeschaltet rausgekommen sind wir
würden es jederzeit wieder machen viel
struggles viel viel Kopfschmerzen mit
der Produktion hier ist die Geschichte
aber leider noch nicht vorbei sondern
für mich und Pad beginnt jetzt die
eigentliche Arbeit ähm denn was ganz
ganz viele Leute immer vergessen ist
dass da noch ein riesen riesen Berg an
Arbeit im Schnitt auf unserer Seite ihr
müsst euch vorstellen das ist so viel
Material stellt euch vorher Lieblings
Youtuber wird jeden Tag bloggen den
ganzen Tag das 7 Tage lang und jetzt
haben wir von diesen Leuten aber sieben
Stück also haben wir quasi 49 ganze Tage
im Block ja und das können wir uns jetzt
alles hinterher schön anschauen die
spannendsten Momente rausschneiden und
das dann hinterher eben zu einer Serie
und zu einzelnen Folgen zusammenbauen so
dass das eben auch Spaß macht sich
anzugucken
hallo wir sind Johannes how wax und wir
stecken gerade mitten im Schnitt von der
Folge 13 ich bin Rico und Designer und
Fotograf in der zweiten Staffel war ich
mit vor Ort um die ganze Produktion
Fotograf zu begleiten daraus ist ein
Bildband entstanden und in der Post
Production bin ich ein Autofahren vor
sich für alle Animation also ganz
besonders wichtig bei so einem Projekt
ist natürlich okay wer macht was und wie
ist die Aufgabenverteilung das war in
unserem Fall so dass Max und ich vorher
und zusammengesetzt haben haben quasi
konzeptioniert wie wollen wir was im
Schnitt machen wie man was haben was
brauchen wir dafür wie sollten im
Idealfall die Grafiken aussehen wie soll
das VoiceOver sein wie sollen die
Challenges eingebunden werden und so
weiter also alle strategischen
Entscheidungen den Schnitt betreffend
haben Max und ich getroffen der Ablauf
ist zur finalen Folge gekommen ist war
eigentlich immer so dass Material wurde
vorher gesichtet von Clemens Patrick und
mir dann habe ich diese gesichteten
Sequenzen zusammengeführt habe die
einzelnen Folgen inhaltlich
zusammengesetzt dann ist das wiederum
alles zu abgewandert für den Feinschnitt
da hat er denn in Kombination mit Rico
die Grafiken eingesetzt also eine diese
drohen Transitions oder auch der Intro
endcard aber auch zum Beispiel die
placements die wiederum Max vorher
gedreht und geschnitten hatte also man
merkt von ganz ganz vielen Teilbereichen
kamen einfach alles zusammen und dann
ist es zu Max in die Endabnahme gegangen
max hat sein Okay gegeben und ist auf
Youtube hochgeladen und alles was für
Youtube relevant ist also Vorschaubild
Titel und so weiter dann eben da
eingepflegt für die Post pro von
Dezember ist weit benutzen wir die
komplette Adobe Creative Cloud für den
Schnitt Premiere Pro für die ganzen
Animationen benutzen wir After Effects
und für die Grafiken in Design und
Photoshow und das läuft alles auf
Windows Rechnern wie auch auf Mac
Rechnern wir sind da irgendwie so ein
bisschen gemischt im Team wir sitzen
auch alle bei uns selber zu Hause dann
muss ich das nicht so vorstellen dass
wir zusammen Büro haben wenn wir
arbeiten alle remote wir können uns
morgens einmal dann begibt sich jeder in
seinen eigenen Tag in seinen eigenen
Workflow aber wir sind halt nicht diese
wie soll man sagen professionelle
Produktionsfirma die einfach alles hat
und die setzt sich dann dahin und kann
losgehen grundsätzlich sind wir
hardwaretechnisch relativ basic
aufgestellt das ist waldstiftplatz mehr
ist es nicht eigentlich in echt sind
hier noch chips-tüten und so ein Kram
drumrum aber das ist es als auf der
Insel gedreht haben haben wir uns
irgendwie gewünscht dass es so wird wie
ein Staffel 1 von der footage Menge hat
nicht geklappt es wurde alles ein
bisschen mehr es ist mehr gefilmt worden
es sind Kandidaten länger drin in der
Staffel 1 sind ja schon zwei Stück am
ersten Tag ausgeschieden über menschlich
viel gefilmt hat Joris der hat wirklich
jede SD-Karte voll geknallt also die
Leute hatten ja zweimal 64 Gigabyte am
Tag wirklich alle voll und da gibt's
natürlich auch Teilnehmer die ein
bisschen weniger gefilmt haben Nova zum
Beispiel was auch gar nicht schlimm ist
ich habe zwei Festplatten die sind
insgesamt acht Terabyte groß und muss
sich vorstellen die Teilnehmer
verbringen 7 Tage auf der Insel und Film
unter Umständen den ganzen Tag und wenn
man sich das dann vorstellt sieben
Teilnehmer potentielle 7 Tage also da
kommt einiges an Material zusammen was
wir dann hinterher sichten müssen
zusammenschneiden müssen und auch die
besten Zähne eben raussuchen müssen aber
natürlich können wir nicht all das mater
mal reinnehmen ist ja klar es ist viel
zu viel wir müssen uns da versuchen auf
die Highlight zu konzentrieren es ist
auch so dass viele Dinge die die
Zuschauer interessiert hätten
wahrscheinlich auch nicht drin sind
deswegen sind wir auch gerade in der
Überlegung das Material der Kandidaten
an Kath hochzuladen damit man halt auch
die ganzen unveröffentlichen Szenen mal
zu Gesicht bekommt die es sich lohnt
anzuschauen parallel zu den Animationen
war ich damit permanent beschäftigt das
ganze Buch Layout zu setzen die 13.000
Fotos auszuwerten und die Highlights
davon in das Buch zu bringen und jetzt
wir sind an dem Stand nach ganzen
testten und jetzt sind wir bei so einer
geilen Version ich glaube die Leute
werden richtig happy damit sein am Ende
ist das Buch 68 Seiten stärker geworden
obwohl das gar nicht so geplant war aber
wir hatten so viel Material geile
Interviews exklusives Bildmaterial was
noch rein sollte und so ein richtig
geiles Produkt zu schaffen definitiv
weil die größte Herausforderung das
Thema Zeit weil von von Panama bis er da
waren und so oft haben wir Folge haben
wir glaube ich fünf Wochen also wir
schneiden jetzt quasi seit dem ersten
Tag wo wieder zurück sind aus Panama
durchgehend bis jetzt und wir sind noch
nicht fertig
bedeutet das sind jetzt ungefähr drei
bis vier Monate die wir ja Vollzeit und
teilweise auch deutlich länger als
Vollzeit daran arbeiten also insgesamt
werde ich locker 400 500 600 Stunden
dafür gebraucht haben für das Design und
Animation für alles rund um servus Wald
also wenn ich das jetzt so grob
überschlagen müsste für eine Folge das
sind vier Leute die arbeiten sieben Tage
die Woche zehn Stunden kommt man so
ungefähr auf 350 Stunden die da pro
Folge investiert werden müssen ja aber
anders ist es in so einem kurzen
Zeitraum auch nicht zu bewerkstelligen
das bedeutet man macht mit dem ganzen
Team quasi kontinuierlich Überstunden
und wir sind leider wieder an dem Punkt
ich hätte es in unserem allerersten
Video auch schon mal erwähnt dass wir an
dem Tag fertig werden wo das Video
online kommt und das ist eigentlich ein
absolute Katastrophe das geht eigentlich
gar nicht aber das ist dann wird dem
Material sonst nicht her und kriegt es
nicht lebendigt da die Teilnehmer ja
gerne mal nicht bekleidet auf der Insel
unterwegs waren gibt es natürlich auch
die ein oder andere Stelle die wir dann
hinterher oder ganz konkret ich
zensieren muss und auch das ist
teilweise ein längerer Prozess als man
vielleicht denkt ja ist ein bisschen
nervig ja wenn wenn knossida das das 20
mal irgendwie mit seinem nackten
arschlöses Bild läuft dann muss eben
diese zensiert diese dieses kleine
zensierfeld auch getrackt werden ja dass
das mit wandert dass das auch nicht
irgendwie dann mal flöten geht sage ich
mal da gucken wir dahin gekauft
teilweise so nach vor dem Bildschirm und
gucken uns genau an dass wir da auch
nichts übersehen kannst halt viel damit
verschießen ne Stimme vor irgendwas
vergisst und dann gucken sich die Leute
doch Twitch an und dann halt jetzt die
Bands was bei uns im Schnitt eine sehr
große Herausforderung also was ich für
meinen Teil sagen kann ist ich habe sehr
viel Zeit in die erste Folge gesteckt ja
also bei der ersten Folge wollte ich
einfach dass wir dann ein richtiges
Brett ins Internet Zimmer ja das einmal
Youtube Deutschland richtig wach wird
und da habe ich einfach so viel Energie
und Liebe reingesteckt das wirklich
alles jeder jeder Musik Übergang jedes
Szene Drop von der Musik wenn man dann
im Nachhinein noch mal drauf achtet
einfach genau stimmig ist das war eine
große Herausforderung aber da habe ich
mich gerne gestellt und ich glaube das
Ergebnis lässt sich auch ganz gut sehen
wir sind ja jetzt schon wirklich fast
drei Monate dabei und man muss sagen es
setzt so langsam so eine Art Lethargie
ein ja also wir haben immer noch extrem
Spaß und sind super froh dass es alles
so erfolgreich ist aber man merkt bei
allen Beteiligten im Schnitt so langsam
ist einfach die Luft raus schlecht mir
geht es sehr schlecht
also ich kann das ganz kurz zwei Sätzen
sagen so ein Projekt zu machen diese
Monate des Schnitts und der
Postproduktion die sind irgendwie ganz
besondere Belastung nicht nur wenn man
14 15 Stunden am Tag vom PC sitzt
sondern auch weil das immer so eine
mentale Belastung ist du weißt okay ich
werde jetzt hier noch die nächsten zwei
Monate drei Monate werde ich hier noch
in meiner Kamera hocken und irgendwelche
Videos Sachen angucken was einerseits
cool ist weil man ist ja der erste der
sieht und der ist dann irgendwie
zusammenfügt aber andererseits macht
einen das auch wirklich müde im Kopf und
irgendwann merkt man nicht mehr dass es
hier in so abschaltet man einfach nur
noch in so einer Parallelwelt lebt so
die Parallelwelt ist dein Monitor die
Leute fordern wir versprechen den
natürlich was und wir wollen halt auch
liefern wir spielen auf jeden Fall den
Druck von außen gerade weil dieses
Projekt schon wieder
abnormales Fähren von Zuschauerzahlen
erreicht gerade so super geile Zeit aber
auch eine wirklich intensive Zeit für
den Kopf und für den Körper und wir
freuen uns auch ein kleines bisschen
mehr das Projekt dann irgendwann mal
vorbei ist und wie auch ein bisschen mal
wieder abschalten können also für mich
persönlich das größte learning war die
Erfahrung in so einem großen Team
zusammen zu arbeiten also sowohl auf der
Insel als auch nach im Nachhinein in der
Postproduction Projekt übergreifend an
eine Sache zu arbeiten oder auch mit
Grafik an oder auch mit Voice Over oder
was weiß ich nicht alles ähm das ist
eine ganz besondere Herausforderung aber
das gibt einem auch viel wenn man nicht
mehr das Gefühl hat so wie z.B noch im
letzten Jahr dass das gesamte die ganze
gesamte Last des Projekts nur auf den
deine Schultern irgendwie ruht ich habe
auf jeden Fall gelernt wie wichtig das
Zeitmanagement ist und seine Tasks auf
jeden Fall vernünftig zu planen und
unter so einen großen Druck zu arbeiten
auf jeden Fall man muss das wirklich
auch noch mal sagen da gehört einiges zu
so ein Projekt über so langen Zeitraum
durchzuziehen über so viele Stunden am
Tag deswegen noch mal vielen vielen Dank
ans gesamte Team also vor allem zu
erwähnen magst natürlich Pad und Klebens
und letztendlich nicht im Schnitt aber
in Animation Rico der wirklichen richtig
geilen Job gemacht hat im ganzen Design
mega geil hat mega Bock gemacht mit
einem zu arbeiten und jetzt ist zum
Glück auch das Licht am Ende des Tunnels
zu sehen und wir sind hoffentlich in
einer Woche durch mit einem danke dass
ihr euer Leben mit uns weggeworfen hat
für drei Monate auch an Dich Johannes
[Musik]